[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing remus lupin hogwarts
professor
werewolf and husband to nym fedora tonks
remus lupin was a british half-blood
wizard born in the year 1960.
like most others he attended hogwarts
and it was there that he befriended the
other members of the marauders
a gang of gryffindors consisting of
remus sirius black
peter pettigrew and james potter however
before he began attending the school
remus was attacked in his early life by
the notorious werewolf fenrir greyback
fenrir sought revenge on remus father
lyle
an attacking remus in the middle of the
night turning him into a werewolf
was the best way to do this the
marauders were completely understanding
of remus condition
and did whatever they could to make his
life seem as normal as possible
after graduating from hogwarts remus and
the marauders joined the order of the
phoenix
an organization that had one goal take
down voldemort and his forces
when pettigrew betrayed the order his
former gang was no more
pettigrew had changed allegiance james
potter had died
and sirius black was sent to azkaban
framed for crimes which pettigrew
committed
for years remus kept a low profile the
dark lord had been defeated by infant
harry
and there was no immediate requirement
for an opposition to dark forces
however in the 93-94 school year we see
remus accept a posting at hogwarts
professor for defense against the dark
arts however one thing that was never
really addressed in the movies
was just how shabby lupin was the first
time that were introduced to lupin's
character
he's described as follows the stranger
was wearing an extremely shabby set of
wizards robes that had been darned in
several places
he looked ill and exhausted though quite
young his light brown hair was flecked
with grey
it's on his case she replied pointing at
the luggage rack over the man's head
where there was a small battered case
held together with a large quantity of
neatly knotted string
the name professor rj lupin was stamped
across one corner
in peeling letters then again at the
sorting ceremony
professor lupin looked particularly
shabby next to all the other teachers
in their best robes malfoy even took
some jabs at him
look at the state of his robes malfoy
would say and allowed to whisper as
professor lupin passed
he dresses like our old house elf so why
did remus have such a derelict
appearance
was he poor or did he just not care as a
professor to harry he's always really
generous
giving him chocolate frogs buying him
butter beer etc
so surely he must have some money right
why wouldn't he just buy a new set of
robes
the truth is remus was really poor and
he only started to make a bit of money
when he got his job at hogwarts
the only way that remus was able to
afford to buy things for harry was
because of his new posting
before that there's no way he could have
possibly spent anything on harry
when he finally started working at
hogwarts he spent what he could on harry
so that he could spoil the son
of his former best friend but he still
wasn't rich
after harry sees lupine on the train his
next encounter with him suggests that
lupin had eaten properly for the first
time
in a while lupin smiled vaguely and
placed his tatty old briefcase on the
teacher's desk
he was as shabby as ever but looked
healthier than he had on the train
as though he had had a few square meals
in the half blood prince we see we miss
discussing his financial situation with
tongs
and i've told you a million times said
lupin refusing to meet her eyes
staring at the floor the time too old
for you too poor
too dangerous and in the order of the
phoenix it's revealed that it's
extremely difficult to find work
when you're a werewolf i know she's a
nasty piece of work though
you should hear remus talk about her
does he know her no
but she drafted a bit of anti-werewolf
legislation two years ago
and makes it almost impossible for him
to get a job jk rowling expanded on this
in an interview
remus lived a hand-to-mouth existence
taking jobs that were far below his
level of ability
always knowing that he would have to
leave them before his pattern of growing
sick
once a month at the full moon was
noticed by his workmates and it has been
expressed that dumbledore changed his
life when he tracked him down for the
posting at hogwarts
once again albus dumbledore changed the
course of remus's life when he tracked
him down to a tumble-down
semi-derelict cottage in yorkshire and
that's why remus lupin
was constantly described as looking
shabby and downtrodden
he was poor and as a werewolf it was
exceedingly difficult for him to find
consistent work that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time
your wizard harry
[Music]
you